il faudra tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir un
paradoxe purement français l'emploi
augmente tout comme les investissements
et le pouvoir d'achat est pourtant très
peu le ressent alors pourquoi perception
et réalité ne font pas bon ménage que
nous dit ce pessimisme généralisé de
l'échec de nos politiques et à quand
remonte la période les français se
disaient heureux
décryptage à suivre sur ce plateau la
société médiatique et politique at elle
cédé la place à la dictature du sarcasme
un livre est au coeur du débat public
depuis quelques jours c'est celui de
frédéric beigbeder
le romancier règle ses comptes avec
france inter dont il a été viré après
une chronique woods s'est sabordée en
direct il est notre grand témoin ce soir
et avec lui un débat exceptionnel avec
des humoristes avec des élus
rires et politiques dérision dangereuse
l'insolence le ricanement sont ils en
train de jeter le discrédit sur nos
démocraties quel est le pouvoir de
l'humour dans la france d'aujourd'hui
faut-il d'être drôle absolument la
drôlerie est elle devenue obligatoire
on en parle dans un instant sur ce
plateau voilà pour le programme hashtag
assez berne oublié
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir frédéric
beigbeder bonsoir soit on est ravis de
vous accueillir vous êtes notre grand
témoin vous allez passer une heure sur
ce plateau en notre compagnie vous êtes
écrivain les français connaissent bien
chroniqueur au figaro et plus à france
inter parce que vous avez été congédié
de phase iii que je suis comme toujours
masque et la plume à une fois par mois
oui oui donc ils vous ont gardé au magic
et la pluie bon instant congédié de
façon assez radicale en une journée
après une forme de suicide en direct il
faut le dire sur les ondes avec une
chronique un les français le savent
maintenant parce que si on a beaucoup
parlé ça fait l'objet de beaucoup
beaucoup d'articles que vous avez
totalement improvisée en direct vous
dirai comment avec le recul vous
regardez ce geste là vous publié
aujourd'hui un livre qui est au coeur du
débat politique
vous le voyez c'est ce petit homme qui
est tout jeune mais mme hodges
on peut dire que c'est l'homme qui
pleure de rire en tous les cas il est
hilare c'est chez grasset on va en
parler longuement on va parler au fond
des relations entre les politiques et
des humoristes est ce que le rire est en
train de fondre envahir le débat public
on le fait dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission mais d'abord les chiffres
les chiffres économiques de la situation
économique qui s'embellissent et ce
paradoxe français
cette semaine les bons chiffres du
chômage ont été publiées dans
l'indifférence quasi générale même si
quelques journalistes en ont parlé et la
perception d'avenir elle est toujours
assez morose assez noir assez pessimiste
bonsoir lehbila grégoire bonjour on en
parle avec vous ce soir vous êtes député
la république en marche de paris vice
présidente de la commission des finances
ici à l'assemblée nationale est bienvenu
claudia senik vous êtes économiste
professeur à sorbonne universités et à
l'école d'économie de paris spécialiste
de l'économie du bonheur une notre
marque est un que vous avez publié il ya
quelques jours pour le conseil d'analysé
économique cela signale sur le bien-être
bien-être et territoires vous nous en
parlera et enfin bon jour est plutôt bon
friis a réservé les chroniqueurs dans
cette émission
chroniqueur pour le quotidien suisse le
temps alors voilà pour les présentations
je vous donne la parole dans un instant
celui qui nous plante le décor à sa
manière comme tous les soirs c'est
stéphane stéphane blakowski si j'ai déjà
compris les dérivés
c'est déjà un événement c'est déjà
peut-être une source de buzz on verra
bonsoir
stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce soir là
si j'ai bien compris myriam les français
ne sont jamais contents par richard
notre ami suisse qu'on va l'expliquer il
le sait déjà mais ce qui est paradoxal
c'est que s'il ya une crise économique
en ce moment en france on le
comprendrait or c'est tout le contraire
le chômage vous l'avez dit est au plus
bas depuis 10 ans que sa rage ou les
français n'ont pas tellement
l'impression
pareil pour le pouvoir d'achat l'insee
nous dit l'an dernier l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat n'a jamais été aussi
forte depuis douze ans a réjoui les
français autant que la baisse du chômage
c'est à dire encore une fois très
modérément alors même d'autres
indicateurs de la croissance
on a plus de croissance que l'allemagne
on a été complexe et si longtemps par
rapport aux allemands on est devant les
allemands on s'en réjouit pas non plus
tout le monde se rend compte que ça va
mieux en france les investisseurs
je dis ce que la france est le pays en
tant qu en tout cas où c'est plus
intéressant d'investir
donc tout va bien tout le monde le
reconnaît sauf les français parce que
les français on leur dit mais vous en
pensez quoi de l'avenir bas pour 77%
jusque non moi je n'ai pas confiance
dans l'avenir mécanique de mon pays donc
les français ne sont pas contents les
ghanéens l'autre n'est pas content à
force
à force ça énerve forcément avec eux des
bonnes notes vous pensez à savoir après
joyeux et ben voila c'était notre
président qui est donc était devant des
jeunes à amiens qui leur a dit écoutez
ça suffit maintenant on a l'impression
si on s'écoute collectivement si on
branche la radio qu'on allume la télé
que tout que tout est terrible enfin on
parle de condition étudiante
comparons la france aux pays est en ce
moment notre pays je trouvais trop
négatif sur lui même dans les
commentaires qu'on a en permanence on a
des difficultés on les affronte
est ce qu elles sont impossibles à
affronter pas du tout est ce que les
choses vont moins bien qu'il ya 20 ans
dans tous les sujets faut il alors si
l'économie va mieux pourquoi ces
mécontentements
c'est très simple mais rien pourquoi
parce que c'est quand même la météo bah
oui regardez la météo a tout compris
l'émission la plus regardée en france
c'est le butin métaux dont vous savez
quand les températures
maintenant il ya deux chiffres le
chiffre officiel est le chiffre ressenti
qui finalement était une température
beaucoup plus basse que le chiffre
officiel c'est pareil pour l'économie
donc indice officiel
il est au beau fixe est en jeu le
ressenti des français il dit non j'ai
pas grisaille envoie pas le soleil lors
comment vous expliquez que le ressenti
ne soit pas d'accord elle est
essentielle car du ressenti a que vous
qui pouvait tout dire ce que vous
ressentez donc fait et vite sa coupe
court à toute conversation
on peut regarder malgré tout les
chiffres de manière générale les
sondages et on voit que malgré tout le
mécontentement l'inquiétude pour
l'avenir il se concentre sur trois
catégories d'électeurs ce qui botte et
colossaux qui vote le pen et ceux qui
votent mélenchon à la bombe les écolos
on peut comprendre on nous dit que
l'économie va mieux
généralement ça va moins bien pour la
nature ça les inquiète mais pourquoi les
électeurs de le pen pourquoi des
électeurs de mélenchon ne se réjouissent
pas des meilleurs chiffres économiques
mais on a l'impression qu'en france il
ya une partie de la population notamment
dans ces catégories là qui plutôt que
des réformes pour améliorer les choses
se dit la meilleure solution aujourd'hui
ça serait une bonne révolution pour
changer tout d'un coup faire table rase
recommencer une façon de bonnes bases
ont forcément dans un pays vous faites
la fête nationale le 14 juillet c'est
sûr que la révolution il ya toujours un
peu l'idée que ça serait plus les roses
bien sûr président emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs assez récemment qui rappelle
qu'au fond nous sommes un peuple
régicide
et oui mais on l'a encore vu là je crois
que cette semaine y avait des
manifestants qui ont promené la tête de
maquereaux au bout d'une pique ce
d'ailleurs
robert badinter poussé un grand coup de
gueule et en disant c'était tout ça
devenait non seulement de n'importe quoi
mais complètement inadmissible alors
pourquoi ça se consentent à ce point sur
ma krombach le sais parce que en france
tous les pouvoirs se concentre sur le
président de la république puisque c'est
lui qui décide de tout c'est un mal qui
le tiennent responsable de tout alors je
vous montrais une courbe et la courbe du
moral des français depuis 2007 donc ça
paraît un peu compliqué à comprendre
c'est simple la barre horizontale fait
la différence entre optimistes et hop et
things dès qu'on est sous la barre mais
dans le pessimisme
en tenant le pessimisme donc vrai que la
france depuis 2007 passe constamment son
temps dans le pessimisme et à sa mort
trois moments où il ya un petit pic
d'optimisme c'est juin 2007 l'élection
sarkozy juin 2012 celle de hollande et
juin 2010 elle sait de macron donc
pendant un mois et français sont
optimistes
on a trouvé gars qui va nous sauver je
veux lui couper la tête
donc il ya peut-être une recherche de ce
truc a en france le pouvoir la
construction de la vème république et un
seul homme décide de tout tant qu'on
aura un monarque à l'elysée on aura
envie de couper la tête
on met beaucoup de choses dans le papier
de stéphane merci olivier grégoire de
parler du temps pour trouver comment
mieux que personne que en politique la
perception c'est la vérité ça il faut il
faut quand même tenir compte de ça c'est
primordial
on peut pas dire ça comme ça d'une
certaine façon c'est une forme de
ballade données qui coiffe acception
prend le pas sur la vérité des faits au
locateur de le dire comme ça mais en
tout cas vous devez en tenir compte
est ce que vous considérez que c'est ces
chiffres-là de ressenti c'est un peu
votre échec alors non je vais commencer
par répondre à la fin de votre chronique
j'aime en général beaucoup et en plus ce
soir évidemment mais le président fait
l'objet d'énormément de critiquer d'une
violence incommensurable merci à robert
badinter d'avoir rappeler certaines
évidences mais les parlementaires ont
aussi leur petit lot fait vrai on n'a
pas nos visages sur des piques encore
mais on a et je pense à une de mes
collègues des femmes parlementaires je
pense à michel perron par exemple
pardonnez moi qui la semaine dernière
pendant ses voeux s'est fait
physiquement agressé il a fait luc
lemaire et les forces de police
interviennent la personne en italie
mettre les mains autour du cou en
essayant de l'étrangler
si vous voulez bien la permanence non
mais parce que là c'est notre intégrité
physique
mais ce cas c'est que la permanence moi
aussi on m'a tagué ma permanence avec et
chrysler perd sa roue du cul sur mon
visage c'est pas grave on apprend à
vivre avec les mails et messages
d'insultés sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
pas grave les donc là vous dites est un
cran en fait c'est un crack d'avancé ça
reste du matériel
quand on s'attaque aux femmes et aux
hommes ça passe un autre cap et je crois
que autant je suis la première à rire et
j'aurai plaisir à rigoler avec les
grands professionnels qui sont autour et
qui seront autour dans la deuxième
partie
autant là je rigole pas du tout et c'est
inquiétant je vais revenir à votre stick
vers ception la perception n'est pas la
réalité mais je pense qu'on a une envie
d'écouter quand on est mais attends j'ai
lu c'est pas nouveau
et moi je vais redescendre un peu dans
le temps je vais même aller avant 2007
et je pense que vous le savez mieux que
moi madame nous avons un pays
charmant qui est depuis allé 20 ans une
vingtaine d'années moi je regardais déjà
les études européennes et mondiales en
2002 nous sommes les champions du monde
du pessimisme c'est pas nouveau ça date
pas de macron sa dette même pas de
hollande et ça date pas de sarkozy nous
avons des chiffres de pessimisme et sont
des études globales fait dans le monde
entier où bien souvent nous sommes
encore plus pessimiste que les slaves
voir que les russes et ce peu importe
les présidents que servir des bassins ne
pourrait pas dans le coup et ses
enquêtes
non mais c'est pas ça c'est que ce
rapport est là quand on entre en
politique on sait qu'on rentre dans ce
champ la norvège depuis 20 ans et pas
que la faute du président vous lui
demandez s'il se sentait responsable
vous dis nord est prise et je vais aller
au bout de la réponse d'abord c'est un
marqueur et j'aurai plaisir à vous
écouter parce que je trouve qu'il est
intéressant d'écouter des professeurs
qui travaille de longue haleine sur ces
sujets là c'est un marqueur français moi
je parle de manioc chaos des pressions
françaises
lisez le bouquin de l'hiver le
conservateur de dons et des prêts
merveilleux malheur france premièrement
ça ça fait longtemps
moi ce qui m'inquiète et je vous rassure
je m'arrête là mais j'aimerais qu'on en
reparle après c'est pour moi on a passé
ici un cap
on est passé sur ces chiffres de la
défiance au déni je prends un exemple
les baisses d'impôts 16 millions de
foyers fiscaux sur 17 millions
vues ont reçu un email que la direction
des finances publiques entre le mois de
septembre et le mois de janvier soit
pour leur dire votre impôt sur le revenu
baisse soit pour leur dire vous payer
moins de taxes d'habitation taxe
foncière pour les autres en septembre je
comprenais que 15 % seulement des
français disent ok il ya des baisses
d'impôts j'y croise cuir 85% n'y croyais
pas elle n'était pas sonnantes et
trébuchantes je pouvais comprendre que
dans la dr jean rivière est différent en
janvier c'est fait on a reçu un email
vous moi mes voisins ma concierge mon
ami tout le monde autour de - 16
millions sur 17 millions et quand vous
allez sur le marché on me dit mais là je
dis mais ça il faut quand même on me dit
mais non c'est plus la défiance celle du
thème vous interrogera vous en tant que
représentants et les hippies bien
méchant mais c'est quoi c'est que la
communication l'éducation la pédagogie
c'est plus profond que de la
communication
c'est une problématique je pense de vous
savez on parle souvent de méthode coué
ou de self fulfilling prophecy en bon
français il ya des pays je pense aux
espagnols je pense aux asiatiques qui
sont dans une dans un self fulfilling
prophecy positif c'est à dire ça va
passer la crise pense à l'espagne 5 ans
ou au portugal ça va passer la crise
mais on va y arriver on va s'en sortir
seule fois ci on y croit mais tony white
ou prophétie auto réalisatrice et l'
inverse
voilà ça va pas ça va pas alors que ça
va mieux mais non ça va pas rater dans
le schéma vous l'avez reçu d'ailleurs
cet email
je crois oui je voudrais dire deux
choses d'abord
le président de la république avait
publié un livre avant son élection
intitulée révolution donc aujourd'hui
évidemment il récolte un peu peut-être
ce qu'il a semé
oui c'est un pays révolutionnaire et en
plus il a promis une révolution qui a
peut-être pas tout de suite eu lieu ou
qui est difficile à organiser
deuxièmement en tant que romancier je
suis forcé d'avouer que le pessimisme
c'est plus esthétique que écrire sur le
bonheur est très difficile ça demande un
talent inouï que je n'ai pas et moi mes
livres ils sont mélancoliques
je me plains je me lamente mes
personnages sont des prix donc je suis à
l'arrêt je pense que ça devrait aller à
travers aussi peut-être de la presse qui
en tant que quatrième pouvoir se sont un
peu dans la nécessité de critiquer parce
que c'est plus valorisant de pointer ce
qui va mal parce qu'elle a plus
l'impression de faire son travail c'est
pas les bonnes j'ai tout pareil sur les
humoristes un humoriste va pas flatter
le pouvoir il est presque enfin je veux
dire par essence obligé de se de
la gueule du pouvoir en place je
voudrais me tourner vers l'économiste
que vous êtes close et scénique pour
essayer de comprendre ce décalage entre
les indicateurs qui sont plutôt bons et
la perception des français d'ailleurs il
ya plusieurs types de perception
perception sur l'avenir du pays
perception sur sa situation à soi déjà
quels sont les quelles sont les données
que vous avez non un observatoire du
bien-être cepremap que je dirige avec
yann algan et andrew clark des collègues
de l'école d'économie de paris enfin et
de sciences po et donc on a ensuite tous
les trimestres le moral le bonheur
l'optimisme du pessimisme des français
donc on peut tracer des courbes comme
celles que vous avez montré enfin je
regardais avec la mienne ça colle et
donc on voit que
on pose des questions sur est ce que
vous sentez heureuse d'être content de
votre vie est ce que vous pensez que la
génération suivante vivra mieux que la
vôtre est-ce que vous pensez que la
prochaine génération donc en france et
aussi en europe livre admet que la vôtre
c'est des questions qui essayent de
saisir l'optimisme et le pessimisme
donc on voit comment il ya une tendance
de fond va vous l'avez dit c'est vrai
que toujours les fronts vous prenez les
belges dans les conditions de vie des
français ils sont déjà un point enfin un
échelon au dessus supérieur sur
l'échelle du bonheur sans rien changer
d'autres non c'est vrai qu'il ya une
espèce de tendance d'insatisfaction
latente qui est qui ne qui ne dépend pas
des conditions de vie je dis pas que les
conditions de vie sont toujours
satisfaisantes jeudi que quelles que
soient ses conditions d'existence
objective il ya toujours une espèce de
danse des générations peut le mesurer en
train de me dire une sorte de socle et
dans votre étude c'est que je la
mettrais mais c'est quand on demande aux
français vous votre vie est ce que vous
en êtes satisfait mais jean le 80% est
l'un des huit sur dix disent oh ouais
moi ma vie ça va ma famille mes
prochaines années c'est le fruit de leur
pays
ça a bien fait cynisme sur le collectif
on sait dire pour l'avenir du pays
l'économie du pays la prochaine
génération tous les collectifs ya un
pessimisme et une insatisfaction et en
revanche pour le côté personnel ça va il
ya eu ce sursaut dont vous avez parlé là
en juin 2017 ou là en fin de compte le
l'écart s'est comblé et puis différence
en fin de compte les gens qui étaient
optimistes pour l'avenir et la prochaine
génération s'est passé de 20% à la
moitié de la population
de même les gens qui étaient contents de
leur vie c'est un coût nettement
augmenté et même pour la prochaine
génération en europe alors que c'était
le moment du brics it's a fait alors que
ça veut dire que tous ces indicateurs le
pouvoir d'achat les impôts c'est pas
rien quand même hein les investissements
qui reviennent et donc qui fait que le
chômage commence à baisser non seulement
ça ne suffit pas du tout pour évaluer
mesure et de diana deux choses ya une
tendance et après un cycle donc la
tendance c'est que c'est vrai qu'en
france elle est plus bas qu plus bas
qu'ailleurs
par contre le cycle le bonheur des gens
la satisfaction l'optimiste sa suis
quand même le cycle déjà faire c'est à
dire que les courbes là si on faisait un
zoom ça fait quand même comme ça quand
l'emploi augmente quand le revenu
augmente les gens sont plus contents ils
ont la corde à sion que c'est quand même
il ya une corrélation si on regarde
quand même décembre 2019 la la courbe de
l'optimisme qui sommeille en décalage
entre la bonne nouvelle
l'euro le moral augmente vraiment mesure
d'un mot parce que les gens sautent aux
emails on voit dans votre étude que vous
avez aussi pris un certain nombre
d'indicateurs la mobilisation des idées
jaune où il fasse la variation du taux
d'abstention le mal être déclarés dans
cette écoute dans cette étude sur le
bien-être et les territoires en
fonctionnement du lieu d'habitation
commencé poker non classés c'est une
étude sur le vraiment le l'impact des
conditions de vie très local des gens
sur sur leur bien-être leur mal être
et puis après leur comportement
politique donc ce qu'on mesure on mesure
comment évoluent seins la note que les
gens se donnent à eux mêmes est ce que
vous êtes satisfait de votre vie de 0 à
10 ils se mettent une note
et puis après nous on regarde tout ça en
agrégé on voit apprendre à regarder
l'évolution au cours du temps entre 2012
et 2017 de l'abstention aux élections
présidentielles comme un signe de
désaffiliation désaffection et on a
regardé la probabilité d'avoir un
événement gilet jaune dans la commune
c'est une étude qui est faite commune
par commune
sur les dix dernières années pour voir
comment ces indicateurs ces trois
indicateurs de mal-être avait évolué au
cours de la période
est ce que vous regardez ils regardent
les si on peut rattacher ça a des choses
qui sont vraiment locales à savoir est
ce qu'il ya des commerces et des
services privés ou publics qui ont fermé
est ce que il ya des écoles qui ont
fermé est ce que l'emploi a baissé dans
la commune
est-ce que les impôts vont augmenter
dans la commune est ce que les
associations y en a moins dans la
commune bref est ce que la vie se retire
localement ou est ce qu'elle est
toujours là est-ce que je peux voilà et
donc on voit que effectivement ces
conditions de vie vraiment de ce qui se
passe autour de moi c'est pas si moi je
suis un emploi ou pas c est ce que
l'endroit où je suis le taux d'emploi
diminuent même si moi je suis un emploi
c'est déprimant de se dire que les
services publics se retire ou les lieux
de socialisation c'est ce que vous
montrez bien une sorte de cartographie
du meurtre il cotait miroir parce que
s'il est la courbe que nous a montrée
stéphane à chaque fois ça monte en
période d'élection présidentielle comme
par hasard c'est la période où les
candidats disent tous aux français vous
êtes formidable on vous promet plein de
choses donc au fond les français adorent
être flatté ils vont bien quand on les
flammes mais on en propose un projet
de ces cinq ans alors qu'il en oeuvre le
programme si tenté qu'il le fasse parce
que macro essaye de faire le pessimisme
en revient donc à essayer le paradoxe à
avancer parce qu'on s'est posé une
question puisque vous dites que ça ne
date pas d'hier
à quand remonte au fond la période où
les français se disaient pleinement
heureux céramique a mené l enquête pour
voir des français heureux il faut
remonter à 1960 à l'époque tout semble
possible
la france s'industrialise la croissance
flirte avec les 6 % et le taux de
chômage est quasi nulle
les français découvrent la société de
consommation
premier électroménager premiers
téléviseurs achetés en masse qu'est ce
que la télévision
a tous je dispose encore cette question
le cinéma font aujourd'hui une réponse
et puis les français font des bébés
beaucoup de bébés c'est le baby boom
bref la france a le moral
alors laissons des français expriment
une confiance dans l'avenir collectif
uniquement pendant la période dite que
j'ai appelé les très heureuse entre 1962
et 1975 s'agit pas de dire que c'est un
âge d'or et que tout le monde est
heureux mais les réponses des sondés
sont plus positives
une embellie de courte durée le premier
choc pétrolier de 73 signe un coup
d'arrêt brutal à cet optimisme ambiant
depuis les français ont le moral dans
les chaussettes
les études le montrent sur l'échelle du
bonheur les français restent à la traîne
et culmine en tête du classement mondial
des pays les plus pessimistes
loin derrière les scandinaves les
inégalités en suède on parle souvent du
modèle suédois ou cinq ans dans les pays
scandinaves sont nettement à répondre
mais en moins accentuée en france et
donc cette faiblesse des inégalités
cette réduction des inégalités elle
permet en tout cas des taux de
satisfaction relevés dans les sondages
qui sont plus mais cela n'explique pas
tout à niveau égal les français croient
moins en l'avenir que leurs voisins y
aurait-il une culture du pessimisme à la
française chez les élites
je dirais qu'il y a peut être
effectivement un tropisme culturel une
tendance dans laquelle le le pessimisme
serait mieux vu que dans d'autres pays
finalement il serait vu comme une forme
de lucidité mais les français ne sont
pas condamnés au pessimisme
pour preuve le moral des ménages
rebondit depuis deux ans voilà il y
aurait-il une culture du pessimisme à la
française elle est pour vous la
chronique à préparer richard vais aller
parce qu'il s'est penché sur la
littérature étrangère le malheur france
est vue par les écrivains européens
alors effectivement griam ce qui est
frappant c'est que quand on se plonge
dans les livres d'écrivains qui ont
sillonné la france ils sont tous frappés
par ce goût non seulement pour le
malheur mais pour la colère et en fait
ça va ensemble or je vais commencer par
mark twain vous savez l'auteur américain
des aventures de huckleberry finn qui
est en france en 1880 on est bien avant
et qu'est ce qu'il dit il dit sur une
chose les français reste inégalable
l'esprit de massacre semble leur revenir
de droit divin
juste avant il comparait les français
aux indiens comanche en disant qu'ils ne
parviennent jamais à s'entendre il adore
les françaises qui sont les plus belles
femmes du monde
mais il ajoute d'une avec une véritable
pic ce tempérament de cette population
qui aiment tellement les deux ailes à
l'époque c'est au sens propre et qui est
incapable de calme contrairement aux
anglais évidemment un peu plus tard en
1900 avec henrie james un autre
romancier américano britannique
il visite les châteaux de la loire c'est
la douceur supposé incarner il est
devant les toiles de la renaissance et
qu'est ce qu'ils constatent il dit
toujours la turbulence les passions les
haines les trahisons les faussetés les
contrastes violents et ce goût infinie
des français pour un point de vue
dramatique et l'accumulation d'horreur
il dit c'est ça l'éternité massive de la
france alors plus tard en récemment
alain les juste avant 1960 on est dans
les années 50
herbert plus tu y es tu un journaliste
suisse allemand qui est un grand ami
dame de raymond aron qui le publiera en
français sont libres à l'heure de son
clocher il dit voyager en france ses
buts est sans cesse sur une personne qui
s'accroche de toutes ses forces et de
toute sa ruse à ces tournants à ses
habitudes et à ses erreurs ses
désillusions accumulées doivent toujours
éclaté afin qu'il soit possible de
surmonter le dépit et de repartir
et c'est ça le moteur français il a été
identifié dans son livre révolution
française par l'actuel correspondante de
vie économistes sophie pedder elle est
en france et une observatrice
extrêmement précises de la france et
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit les
français se plaignent parce qu'ils ont
besoin de croire indispensable la
révolution on y revient il leur faut le
malheur d'aujourd'hui pour justifier
leur combat dans un combat évidemment
glorieux afin de se dépasser
le malheur en france c'est le pétrole
c'est le carburant français le mot de la
fin c'est notre carburant salle était
contre nous mêmes andré gide avait dit
on ne fait pas de bonne littérature avec
de bons sentiments c'est très compliqué
de décrire sans être niais sur quelqu'un
d'heureux et donc le désespoir je pense
vraiment c'est un moteur sur le planche
par littéraire après moi j'ai j'avais
fait une suggestion au président de la
république avait d'ailleurs jean bédard
le livre en parle dans mon lit en est
bien la solution on la connaît je lui ai
dit de légaliser le cannabis comme ça
les gens seraient beaucoup plus détendue
dans ce pays
lire plus le cannabis thérapeutique à
renforcer certains mauvais tribout me
l'accordé
bce sur la libéralisation de c'est vrai
merci merci beaucoup claudia senik merci
richard vous restez avec nous on va
essayer de peut-être de rire un peu ou
pas avec votre livre vous restez avec
nous également olivier grégoire on en
vient donc à notre grand débat et se
livre ce pavé dans la mare que vous vous
jetez parce que au fond personne tout le
monde n'arrête pas d'en parler ça a
suscité un vrai débat public
vous allez très loin dit qu'à une forme
de fascisme qui seraient à l'oeuvre
jusqu'aux un discours qui fait un bon
match il a montré du doigt il ne fait
pas sûr qu'il reconnaît lui même être un
élément de cette double et j'ai aussi
coupable vous avez fait partie de cette
société du spectacle vous le dirait si
vous en êtes encore aujourd'hui des
humoristes et des politiques ont-ils
toujours fait bon ménage
ou pas avant d'accueillir nos invités
vous allez voir ça vaut ça vaut la peine
voyez le sujet d' hélène bonduelle et
dames et attire c'est vous qu'en cas
d'échec au permis de chasse j'ai eu à
pâtir
il faut parfois attendre quatre mois
pour pouvoir leur passé c'est beaucoup
trop long
beaucoup trop cher les jeunes ne veulent
pas souffrir ne peuvent pas s'offrir une
telle dépense et les jaunes ils ont
besoin de tirer le vide et les douilles
l'image d'un politique qui rit face à un
humoriste n'est pas nouvelle
depuis des années ils y sont confrontés
lorsqu'ils participent à une interview à
la radio ou à la télé mais souvent les
politiques rit jaune face aux sarcasmes
des humoristes dans son dernier livre
frédéric beigbeder qui a officié sur
l'antenne de france inter
dans une chronique matinale pointe du
doigt les rapports entre les politiques
et les humoristes principalement ceux de
son ancienne maison et y at il une
dérive de ce qu'il appelle la machine à
vannes
l'humoriste s'est il transformé en
militant alex vizorek humoriste chez
france inter s'en défend
quand j'ai déjà une sensibilité de
gauche jamais je vais inciter les gens à
voter pour d'autres gens ma façon de
travailler c'est qu'il faut absolument
que je sois drôle mon avis doit pas
prévaloir sur
la drôlerie de ce que je raconte voilà
humoriste et politiques peuvent-ils
cohabiter sur un même plateau
joue-t-il vraiment à armes égales
problème des politiques c'est qu'ils
veulent gagner sur toute la ligne
c'est à dire que quand leurs terres ils
sont très contents qu'on les voit rire
avec nous type sarkozy avec gerra à
willy tape dans la main quasi à la fin
qui ce que tu m'as ferrée quand tu
imites machin et les cotes on est plutôt
la dent dure alors ça ça leur va pas non
plus parce que du coup ils peuvent pas
répondre
la fameuse phrase de beigbeder on ne
débat pas avec un clown une carte
blanche parfois à la dérive que
condamnent fermement dans son livre
frédéric beigbeder comme quand un
humoriste jarville vanhoenacker ironise
sur le viol face au ministre des comptes
publics gérald darmanin
alors qu'il vient d'être blanchi par la
justice et a des casseroles à nous
envoyer un nom la plainte pour viol non
lieu l'abus de faiblesse la session
suffirait donc c'est bon fond ce manga
on est avec toi et pour tous ces petits
conseils on va pas être vaches comme tu
es encore aux comptes publics qu'ils ont
de faire à béthune ou fils 200 boules de
la main à la main ça nous paye le
restaurant le kit répartie silencieuse
tout est possible tout ce que vous
pouvez être comique manifestement en
2009 c'est une chronique de stéphane
guillon sur le comportement de dominique
strauss kahn avec les femmes qu'il sait
rien dit est arrivé sur le plateau
quelques minutes après les rapts
politiques tous les responsables
d'action publique - ont le droit humain
de devoir sans doute d'être critiqués
par les humoristes l'humour c'est pas
drôle quand c'est principalement de la
méchanceté
les politiques ont-ils finalement et
guenifi y perdre de se confronter un
billet d'humour
moi je pense qu'ils ont tout à y gagner
6 il gérera bien et certains l'ont
compris
donc il faut ni être trop dans dans le
brancardage du comique à la fin ni est
trop dans leurs caisses que vous me
faites rire je pense qu'il faut trouver
un peu le compromis accepté cette
façon-là d'être critiqué france 2 avait
tenté l'expérience dans l'émission
politique
la carte blanche humoristique de
charline van snick heures en fin
d'émission avait plutôt refroidi
françois fillon invité ce jour là
humoriste et politique sur un même
plateau
la chaîne a depuis mis fin mais cette
cohabitation
est ce pour ça
et pour débattre de ce sujet rire et
politique
un magnifique plateau bonsoir françois
rollin voiliers de magnifiques sur ce
plateau aussi beaucoup beaucoup de gens
j'ai apprécié je le dis alors vous êtes
comédiens vous êtes scénariste vous avez
contribué à de nombreuses émissions de
nombreux spectacles aussi on peut citer
palace le grand maître c'est les
guignols de l'info vous avez été l'un
des premiers auteurs vous êtes à
l'affiché du moteur arrière des
créateurs l'un des trois créateurs
c'est corrigé dix prochains films très
attendu par beaucoup de cp beaucoup de
français d'alexandre astier kaamelott et
vous avez travaillé à france inter ça
nous intéresse d'avoir un peu votre
votre regard sur sur cette expérience
jérôme de verdière bonsoir soit vous
êtes journaliste vous présenter la revue
de presse sur paris première depuis dix
ans et vous êtes l'un des auteurs de
laurent gerra humoriste tous les matins
sur rtl dans un autre style que les
humoristes de france inter bonsoir et
bienvenue à ron vous êtes humoristes
vous jouez sur la scène du théâtre
edouard vii c'est un stand-up qui
s'appelle en vrac jusqu'au 20 février
vous nous direz vous comment vous
abordez ce métier et comment vous parler
des politiques
joue-t-il à armes égales les politiques
et les humoristes est ce que quand tu
mets vous allez nous dire bien noir dans
une matinale mais vous y étiez jusqu'à
récemment au fond on a droit au débat
j'ai eu l'impression d'ailleurs en
voyant le montage que vous avez bien
fait que peut-être on arrive à un moment
où c'est difficile de discuter
effectivement en mettant face à face des
hommes politiques qui ont des
responsabilités et des clowns
irresponsable dont le boulot est d'être
marrant et j'ai l'impression que
peut-être en arrivant aux limites de
l'exercice qu'il faudrait peut-être tout
simplement séparer les choses ça a déjà
été un peu faire france inter avant il y
avait davantage
passage de témoin laon mais si je te
mettais d'un juste charline van acker à
7h55
oui c'est ça oui cela doit être
maintenant il ya moins la rencontre
voilà donc ça a été ça a été déjà pointé
du doigt comme un problème cette
impossibilité au fond de débat de vous
parlez dans votre livre d'immunité
humoristique
oui je crois que c'est presque seul
métier dont le discours est disons
n'appelle pas de réponse ne supporte pas
la critique
c'est assez étrange mais c'est comme ça
il ya une immunité que n'ont ni les
députés ni les hommes politiques ni les
écrivains ni toutes sortes d'or qu'il
n'ya pas de temps de parole pour
répondre parce que ça n'est pas le lieu
c'est pas seule marche pas c'est que
l'humour est sacré il ya une
sacralisation aussi de l'humour le
caricaturiste et bien on le sait en
france et c'est un métier en deuil aussi
c'est un métier qui a coûté la vie à des
gens donc au du coup on respecte sa
infiniment et peut-être on peut plus
tellement il répondre ça pose une
question par ailleurs je dis aussi dans
mon livre que beaucoup de comics en ce
moment se retrouve élu dans des
démocraties dans des pays des comics
donc ça aussi ça c'est se dire peut-être
que tient le pouvoir le vrai pouvoir il
n'est peut-être pas là où l'on croit
c'est peut-être pas les hommes
politiques qui alors nous reste ils sont
d'accord sur le populisme affaibli style
la parole politique tout ça c'est on va
y venir mais olivier vraiment vous
voulez redoutez vous êtes souvent dans
les matinales radio
les redoutés les humoristes ou pas non
moi je sur ce plateau je suis la caution
pas drôle parce que je suis une
politique mais en vrai dans l'assemblée
je suis plutôt la caution marrante de je
me prends pas je crois pas trop au
sérieux
la vie est trop grave pour se prendre au
sérieux le seul truc c'est que je pense
comme l'expliquent bien d'ailleurs
frédéric beigbeder dans son bouquin
l'humour est partout en fait quand vous
vous rappelez d'aider certains anciens
qui comme coluche ou qui m'ont nourri ou
comme des proches c'est vrai qu'on sait
c'est un moment assez décapant et je
fais attention que j'ai quand même un
grand monsieur l'humour à ma droite donc
vous allez terminer les les propos mais
il ya un truc et on pouvait se foutra
s'est ardemment de la gueule des
politiques mais les politiques je pense
qu'un marché de pasqua demain avait
aussi un peu ardemment le droit de
répondre avec humour et de dire des
choses qui n'étaient pas forcément
aujourd'hui corbeyrier quiero piégée
politique ça c'est que l'humour est
partout l'humour est devenu
politiquement correct on ira plus loin
parce que pour moi ce qu'on a vu
notamment sur gérald harlin c'est plus
que du monde c'est de l'ironie c'est de
la moquerie et du ricanement c'est leur
également été un peu trop léger ouais
c'est cruel c'est pas loin de la cruauté
en tout cas c'est une méchanceté ce pas
exactement le bon mais c'est de l'ironie
on n'est pas dans l'humour positif on
parlait négatif en intro de négativisme
français du pessimisme français
il ya de l'humour qui portent vers le
haut il ya du monde qui enfonce en bas
c'est un humour qui concernant les
politiques nous enfonçant bas à chaque
fois et quand vous essayez alors moi je
suis une petite parlementaire et je le
tente pas souvent je vais vous dire
quand vous essayez vous parce qu'on est
quand même des bonshommes et des bonnes
femmes normaux quand on est député ou
autre vous peut-être d'avoir un bon mot
ou d'essayer d'être comme vous êtes dans
la vraie vie de faire une blague aux
achats a non là désolé mais ça passe pas
tout de suite vous est rattrapé par la
patrouille pourquoi il a dit ça il s'est
permis de l donc et donc je dois ne vous
est pas là du martégal cc bon joue pas
du tout à armes égales
est ce d'ailleurs au détriment du
politique qui devrait pouvoir aussi se
lâcher un peu plus et on est dans un
espace de cercle vicieux qui pour moi
est grave parce que sas a contraint le
politique est dans une espèce de posture
assez sérieuse c'était assez bien résumé
par le monsieur de france inter soit on
se marre trop et c'est pas bien soit on
se marre pas les couleuvres mais moi je
partage ce point de vue sur le fait
qu'on a maintenant à sa bande
d'humoristes qui sont plus des petits
commerçants de de la vanne et plus des
professionnels du dénigrement que deux
véritables d'humoriste mais pour autant
je ne me sens pas fautif et ya pas très
longtemps j'ai fait une petite table
ronde avec l'ami alain finkielkraut et
on a tous les deux dit publiquement aux
au personnel politique battez vous
défendez vous à arrêter d'accepter ça
c'est eux qui ont commencé à accepter ça
vous parliez des guignols il ya un
moment où les guignols sont devenus
l'endroit où on avait le droit de tout
dire et les politiques s'y précipitent
en demandant leur marionnette il venait
se faire écharper
là-bas banon n'acceptait plus à défendez
vous battez vous c'est tout ce que je
peux vous dire tous ces hommes
politiques quand vous vous faites aucune
aura forcément comme ça ils peuvent se
définit il l'aurait vrais gens ils ont
un mauvais rôle mais il faut bien ils
ont qu à se battre ainsi trop et ils ont
qu à protester ils ont qu'à dire at-elle
émission qui leur donne le mauvais rôle
ou par exemple effectivement il ya une
humoriste qui va se de leur
gueule sans qu'ils aient le droit de
répondre après ils ont qu'à dire je ne
viens pas mal motifs d'achat qui peuvent
vous étiez à france inter jusqu'à il ya
quelques années il ya trois ans le livre
de frédéric beigbeder c'est aussi une
charge contre c'est contre ces
humoristes militants ces gauchistes qui
serait au fond uniquement porté par une
forme de bien pensante et qui aurait
tendance à vouloir l'imposer
vous partagez cet avis la wii alors
gauchistes ça me semble un peu un
raccourci mais elle a bien poussé
certains à les toutous france inter et
ou radio france et est teinté de cette
espèce de bien pensants ce où vous devez
et c'est l'art ensemble de votre salaire
vous devez pouvoir pratiquer
l'indignation sur commande la compassion
sur commande aussi
donc voila et tout ce qui sort de là est
mal vu par la station moi j'ai eu à dire
que ces différences et des raisons qu'il
existe oui oui de dirigeants les
animateurs voilà par exemple je me
souviens que j'avais eu un un petit
incident et patrick cohen le jour où
manuel valls avait pris l'avion et que
ces deux gamins pour aller voir ma
fenêtre et cohen faisait quasiment une
émission spéciale pour dire à quel point
on était indigné envies de femme puis
moi j'avais dit à l'antenne et il en a
beaucoup voulu j'habite je crois que
c'est un mauvais combat vous savez
patrick si le premier ministre est en
bonne santé moi je pensais c'est bon
pour nous tous c'est pas pour les
courbes à la détention de la viande ça
eh ben ça c'est très mal vu vous devez
voilà et quand on vous dit réfugiés
syriens vous devez tout de suite avoir
une larme médias comme ça sinon ça veut
dire que vous êtes complice du malheur
est bon et
rendez les reliefs d'attitude très très
envahissante
effectivement comment vous réagissez
vous au procès qui est fait aux
humoristes alors de grande écoute parce
qu'il faut quand même expliqué que ça
marche très très bien
au fond il ya quand même une demande et
il ya des gens qui veulent voir au fond
la tête de l'inviter souvent politiques
se faire un peu dézinguer non je pense
que frédéric et françois pointe le doigt
sur quelque chose qui est quand même
particulier qui est effectivement en
l'occurrence france inter où les
humoristes sont tous d'ailleurs il se
déclare même de gauche
moi je pense que l'humour que
l'humoriste quand il traite de deux
politiques ou d'actualités
il doit être ni de droite ni de gauche
il est drôle déjà pour commencer
le problème c'est que les bouchons des
bouffons du roi fréquent par l'élégante
les bouffons veulent devenir roi et que
les rois deviennent des bouffons ça le
véritable ce qui enlève un arrivé voilà
et est à la fois les humoristes enfin
moi j'ai entendu finkielkraut qui est
mon idole par ailleurs dire que tous les
aucun humoriste aujourd'hui pouvait se
moquer du féminisme de l'écriture
inclusive de l'anti racisme etc
j'avais envie de lui dire arrêtez alain
d'écouté france inter d'avoir vous
faites du mal
écouter rtl avec laurent gerra qui se
moque de tout ça mais qui se moque aussi
de marine le pen qui se moque aussi de
jean luc mélenchon de greta tunes back
de tout le monde
enfin voilà l'humour qui est partout
d'humour qui envahit tout est-ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'on vous avez
du pouvoir en tant qu'humoriste non non
personnellement un grand pouvoir non je
pense avoir un une possibilité de dire
les choses mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
toujours nous poser la question est-ce
que je vraiment en question mon propre
public donc en tout cas quand on prend
les exemptions ou en tout cas moins
inspirés comme coluche ou desproges les
plus l'impression que quand j'écoutais
ça eux meurent pme remettez en question
plutôt qu'il me confirmer dans ce que je
pensais et je pense qu'un humoriste des
qui va dans le sens de son public
il crée un système et donc ils crime
bien pensants ce quelque part de son
public qu'ils l'écoutent et donc on
mange
quand on extérieur de dire ben et le
monde n'est pas inclus dans le système
donc ça nous embête et sur l'engagement
politique des artistes engagés des
humoristes il y en a toujours eu jusqu'à
1 aura deux matches trouve enfin en tout
cas quand on me demande si je suis un
humoriste engagé jeudi toujours non
parce que j'ai trop de respect pour les
gens qui sont vraiment engagés dans les
vraies causes qui se lève le matin pour
aller s'occuper des sdf ou s'occuper de
malades etc
ça c'est l'engagement en fait c'est de
faire de faire une action elle prendre
un risque orageux mort intellectuelle
que ses prix mais jamais commencé début
octobre guy bedos il ya quelques années
voilà enfin que les risques qui prend
réel à part de faire une blague a gelé
un monde comme le dit frédéric on est
protégés par des plaques ce we met fin
au pied on va avoir un vrai meneur mais
c'est pas vous voudriez management au
mettre en avant vos convictions vos
options politiques vos engagements dans
vos spectacles
ah non moi j'ai pas envie de tout ça
parce que moi ce qu'ils voient pas ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de me dire à quel
point moi je suis con 20 mai ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ça c'est de savoir
qu'est ce qui est con en moi et qui fait
que j'essaie d'avoir une stature et un
statut social en essayant de ressembler
à quelqu'un de bien mais au fond de moi
il ya quand même un humain qui a plein
de défauts c'est ça qui m'intéresse
d'aller chercher ce qu'est ce qu'ils en
quoi à l'intérieur de moi il ya du
racisme en quoi à l'internement il ya du
sexisme et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
d'aller gratter donc voila vous posez
des questions sur une population qui en
réalité a énormément changé depuis 30
ans la population des humoristes elle a
changé parce que depuis à peu près 30
ans a commencé la marchandisation du
rire et la marchandisation nous a amenés
à aux fêtes communale l'humour est un
produit donc il ya un marché et quand ya
un marché bien il ya forcément des gens
qui eux sont dans la logique de marché
essaye d'en vendre un maximum c'est à
dire quoi précisément à la main
traditionnelle
c'est quelqu'un qui dit ce qu'il pense
aujourd'hui l'humoriste est pas quelqu
un qui disent qu'ils pensent est un
commerçant dont acquis qui a intérêt
puis c'est son intérêt de commerçants à
dire ce que les gens ont hâte ans qui
vit dans une forme d'injonction
mécanique à rire aujourd'hui en fonction
d'un certain mal de critères comme le
comme tous les commerces si j'ouvre une
pizzeria je vends les pizzas qui ce jeu
mais sur ma carte les pizzas qui se
vendent bien pâli monflanquinois
ce qui est intéressant je compare
souvent ça et de la restauration il ya
le nom mais c'est intéressant de
l'industrialisation du rire il ya le
mcdo il ya l'étoile et ea le petit beast
celui qui fait de la bistronomie il ya
celui qui essaie de créer quelque chose
il ya plein de niveau 2 dans la
restauration mais dans l'humour dans
l'humour il ya plein de niveaux
françois rollin et un statut d'étoilé ou
non mais j'ai un statut de bistrot nome
qui et qui commence à faire son truc il
mcdo là parce que c'est à dire bien sûr
mais on vous dit nourrir les gens
des images qui font des zéniths donc
c'est on n'est plus dans l'humour de
masse 101 sans dénigrer ça il faut aussi
ça il faut qu'ils aient ça parce que
forcément les magyars qui est
responsable de cette marchandisation
après vide le vide idéologique actuel
c'est qu'en l'absence d'utopie en
l'absence de signification la plainte
peut être à l'absence d'intellectuels
aussi qui est qui est une vraie vision
du monde
eh bien je pense que dans ce vide là les
humoristes ont un peu pris la place des
penseurs et c'est là où ça devient un
préoccupe mais en applique irresponsable
ça c'est comme si vous demandez qui est
responsable de la prostitution qui est
responsable de la société de
consommation
ben on sait pas très bien et c'est la
course à l'audience l'audience qui fait
qu' on demande aux demandes en
d'humoristes qui travaillent dans les
grandes radios au fond d'appuyer sur le
bouton en fonction d'une 2 l'auditoire
et politiques sont aussi un peu coupable
quand même parce qu'il pourrait enfin
ils peuvent avoir une hauteur de vue qui
n'est pas toujours c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
celle de l'époque quand on voit le
président de la république posait avec
deux jeunes hommes antillais qui font
des doigts d'honneur torse nu et
personne n'a obligé de se mettre à de
s'abaisser à ce niveau là personne n'a
obligé c'est pas un humoriste qui l'a
obligé à voir et je rebondis sur ce que
disait tout à l'heure françois quand il
ya marine le pen qui refusent de
d'écouter les humoristes de france inter
en l'occurrence un c'est son droit et de
la raison
en fait elle a raison ils doivent se
battre ils doivent se battre pour un
titre personnel je refusais quand
j'étais chez chez cauet n'est dans la
matinale d'inter je refusais de dénigrer
quelles que soient les opinions sur lui
deux des grès de dénigrer un homme ou
une femme politique et venaient parce
qu'il n'avait pas le droit de réponse
derrière donc moi je veux bien m'amuser
à dénigrer quelqu'un si ensuite il peut
claquer le beignet avec beaucoup de
d'esprit et de mais là c'est le système
c'était il ya l'invité puis après
l'humoriste lui casse du du matériel sur
le dos et souvent ça c'est assez facile
il ya je trouve intéressant le sujet sur
de gauche pas de go sur france inter
j'aimerais bien dire un mot sur ce que
vous avez sur le président aussi je
crois qu'en fait on s'en fiche un peu de
savoir si c'est pas mon sujet moi de
savoir si france inter
je m'en suis non plus parce que ça
commence par là mais je gardais le gel
de tous les temps
ce que je pense assez grave j'aurais
juste codesa dans le débat sans jouer à
la pessimiste mais bon allez on se marre
on se marre ça dézingue du politique à
tour de bras ça fait de l'audience on se
marre ça dézingue du politique tout ça
est plutôt chouette ça t'a pas plutôt
sur les volets de droite de la politique
actuelle et ça se dit de gauche mais je
pense jeux wii qui a pas de couleur
politique à la façon dont les politiques
se font taper par les humoristes je
crois que c'est le politique qui soit de
gauche ou de droite en réalité qui est a
priori la source
plus que de l'humour mais des moqueries
et au même titre qu'il est plus facile
d'écrire sur le malheur que sur le
bonheur il est toujours très chic dont
café les dîners les machins d'aller
casser du politique
on l'a fait on le fait on le refera les
français sont comme ça c'est aussi dans
notre mental moi j'étais là tu revenir
sur le rire j'ai ça va mais la nourrice
a nourri à une certaine forme de
messages nourrir peut-être
éventuellement une série d'une forme
c'est que c'est en train et j'aurais
l'opposé la 2de terminé et vous le dites
avec plus de violence que je le dis je
vais pas lire à l'antenne mais le mot
est plus fort on se fait terminé à coups
de lattes dans des matinales et après on
dit c'est bizarre quand même les
français n'ont plus confiance dans les
politiques et les politiques sont tous
des comptes non pas réduire ses impacts
comment ces réponses at-elle mais ignol
recherches commencées après la
contradictoires france qu'on arrive
aussi et on va en parler je pense c'est
pas anormal que certains politiques se
disent bas plutôt que d'aller prendre de
la hauteur de vue là tu j'adhère à c est
ce que vous avez dit moi je vais plutôt
me vautrer dans la fange humoristique et
ça fait du pp griots et sa fille outre m
mais plus on réserve à venir à
l'attention des enseignants du coup tout
ça nous amènera des combos qui gouverne
le chauffeur ellison et moi juste une
petite question je vous donne la parole
les politiques aussi badine sur certains
plateaux télévision d'état sais-tu
s'amusent ils vont chez dans certaines
petites phrases c'est une pression tombe
bien c'est le nom dans des matinales
l'âge élargit un peu le débat il ya des
politiques qui compte chez cyril hanouna
qui voit là sa vérité vous moi je le
regrette
moi je le fais pas et je suis d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit rollin à deux anciens
ministres aussi un du gouvernent les
bleus je maintiens la vérité que vous
représentez complètement je maintiens
mon point de vue et rollin a raison on a
le droit de refuser on a le droit de
dire non et on ne le fait pas et crient
haro ne vous lirez agir on nous tape
dessus et à la fin il faudra pas
s'étonner si on veut plus être élus je
pense que il ya quand même les
politiques ce cap passé dessus entre
pour se suffire à cette violence là faut
pas la violence en plus c'est pas
forcément toujours nécessaire je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord mais
maintenant c'est vraiment de la moquerie
elle existe après vouloir qu'on va pas
commencer à se victimiser parce qu'il ya
quelques chroniqueurs qui en effet vont
parfois loin c'est le principe d humour
c'est d'aller aussi flirté avec les
limites si on va pas flirter avec les
limites on arrête tout de suite dé faire
des blagues et dans ce cas là faut dire
on arrête de rigoler parce que ça veut
dire qu'on va à la messe de mon propos
mais bon d'accord je sais ce que je veux
dire c'est que je dis juste que quand tu
as des vins sur hem qui vont bien et des
français qui vont tous voter
je pose la question de la défiance
qu'est-ce que ça amène avec des chants
et cantiques je dis pas que j'ai raison
et tort dans mon point de vue des
matches où je pose la question est ce
que les humoristes ont vraiment un tel
poids
ou est-ce que les gens franchement oui
alors elles arriveront jusqu'à déjà allé
dans un bar pmu allez vous asseoir vous
verrez qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de
s'aimer comme on le faisait nous même
entre nous mais comme si oui y voit la
violence en politique
et vous vous vous venez vous entre vous
et c'est d'avoir les moyens la dureté
pardon vous ne pouvez pas comparer la
dureté du combat politique
non oui la politique c'est dur et oui on
trouvera taillon très juste mais c'est
en prendre en plus c'est à dire si je
pense que si public est friand de cette
violence là c'est parce que il ya une
injustice qui est vécu qui fait que le
fait de faire des blagues sur les
puissants ça leur rend un peu de justice
là où on a l'impression d'avoir vécu et
donc c'est là que ça m'inquiète
et c'est l'amérique et les rythmes et
les bras sont ces documents copiés mais
ça ne sera pas voilà mais ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'une violence dans une
société se concrétise un moment dans un
propos et il faut dire que la case
humoriste qui concrétise un propos qui
est violent mais il est pile et je sais
pas mais sur le net ce réceptacle
non moi j'ai juste une touche sexy parce
que celle d'aurélien collin chez vous
c'est pas d'une zone rouge reste la
raison toujours dire qu'il a raison
c'était non haroun a raison c'est vrai
que les humoristes se défend toujours en
disant nous combattons les puissants
nous sommes les nous sommes un garde-fou
disons la vérité aux puissants
heureusement que ikea ça le problème
c'est que quand ça devient un humour
permanent un humour de fonds comme il ya
des musiques d'ascenseurs et que toute
la journée on entend ça pas que sur
france inter par tout ça disqualifie 1
je le fais pas de politique et c'est
devient pas le bal à la commandite sa
touche entre les puissants de ma qualité
de l'humour un nouveau prouvé et même
une vengeance d'intuition on évoque sur
le discours critique et sur discours
critique même extrême nous sommes tous
d'accord ce que nous dénonçons c'est
cette espèce de dérive démago poujadiste
qui consiste à discréditer en permanence
le personnel mais qui menace la qualité
surtout qui baisse la qualité de
l'humour parce que l'industrialisation
la qualité de tout tu ne de toute une
frange d une vraie responsabilité
d'avoir discrédité politique visant les
ministères des gros cons des incapables
et ça vous inquiète françois rollin vous
avez l'impression que quoi que les
politiques à force d'être discrédité
s'est pas uniquement
ge se disent les humoristes les rigolo
de service sur le personnel politique a
des effets négatifs
c'est à dire qu'effectivement la jeune
génération
on va dire bien plus facilement qu'on ne
le disait autrefois wiba tous tous
pourris des gros fans et la justice je
connais même pas si un humoriste dit un
ministre tu es un con en fait il fait
pas son métier ça c'est pas drôle
déjà donc il est exclu du terrain de
l'humour donc on ne devrait même pas en
parler c'est pas bien de le faire et
c'est pas drôle surtout c'est nul mais
moi je voulais juste parler encore
revenir sur la hauteur de vue
j'ai une anecdote qui me revient
c'est jean amadou qui était un
chansonnier j'ai eu la chance de
commencer la revue de presse avec lui et
il m'avait raconté une anecdote il avait
créé le bébête show juste avant les les
guignols quelques années avant et il
allait très loin très fort dans le bébé
de chaud il est muté enquêtait président
de la république à ce moment là une
grenouille qui se prenait pour dieu et à
la fin du deuxième septennat de
mitterrand et il savait qu'il allait
mourir enfin j'ai été très malade etc
il rencontre il fait il convoque jean
amadou jean mas 12 10 il va me pourrir
ça va être horrible et et pour prévenir
le truc jean amadou lui dit vous savez
monsieur le président les français vous
ont fait deux fois président de la
république
moi moi j'ai fait mieux je vous ai fait
dieu est là
françois mitterrand malade vieux lui
répond cette réputation que vous m'avez
fait étaient très exagérés les gens là
12 ou qu'est-ce que je vais me prendre
très exagéré parce que voyez-vous dieu
est immortel et je ne le suis pas est ce
qu'on peut imaginer ce dialogue entre
deux personnes très cultivé très bonne
dans leur métier j'allais dire l'une et
l'autre les mêmes aujourd'hui avec un
humoriste d'aujourd'hui est un politique
d'aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr c'est
pour ça que je pense que le label
viennent pour sur la question
des gouvernants parce que vous en parlez
beaucoup dans votre livre dans certains
pays pas partout il gouverne un donald
trump qui a été un héros de la télé
réalité1 zéline ski qui était comique
professionnelle en france ça n'est pas
le cas mais il ya eu lui en 1981
souvenirs souvenirs
aujourd'hui vous vous prenez au sérieux
abbas est d'abord c'est surtout vous qui
prenez ça au sérieux puisque vous
m'invitez d'ailleurs je vous en remercie
mais effectivement ma candidature pour
vous expliquer oui je sais c'est
l'endroit où vous parlez vite pour qu'on
n'ait pas le temps de parler mais je
vais m'habituer parce que je les ai déjà
vu l'émission bat candidature est très
sérieuse dans la mesure où je fais plus
de chances d'avoir des voix que les
autres candidats qui se présentent quoi
tout simplement qu lui mais enfin 80 il
a ouvert une brèche c'est sûr jusqu'à
avant de se retirer les théâtres ans à
catalina convaincu de se retirer à moins
qu'il ne se soit présenté
c'est pas ce qui se serait passé laure
est élu ou pas ce qu'il aurait fait
battre françois mitterrand que
mitterrand n'aurait pas été élu et
giscard était reconduit on sait pas trop
c'était c'était un moment assez
incroyable quoi et qui a créé un
précédent et ensuite il ya eu beppe
grillo en italie sauf que c'est pas
drôle ce qu'il fait y là il n'y pas eu
mort east il devient une politique c'est
ça le problème devient les dégâts j'y
vois la balle alors cela risque de
fausser jumoristes nourrissent une forme
de désengagement manon de dégager ont su
pourraient faire en sorte qu'on soit
comme en ukraine ou pourquoi pas un
boris johnson qui a beaucoup avec le
break dit si vous avez un débat au avec
d'un côté quelqu'un qui dit comment il
voudrait réformer le pays c'est chiant
et en face quelqu'un il dit vous êtes
tous des cons vous êtes tous des
vous en foutez plein les fouilles
votez pour moi si vous voulez dégager
tous et tous ces escrocs évidemment ben
malheureusement le deuxième à une
position plus confortable que de parler
de réformes même mentalité
c'est en dire aux électeurs ne vous y
trompez pas même quand un humoriste vous
amuse beaucoup rigolé bien c'est à ses
blagues mais demandez vous s'il a
vraiment les épaules pour diriger le
pays et pour être aux affaires
aaron réponse en ce qui concerne coluche
la réponse et il le savait bien lui-même
et non bien sûr ce garçon là n'avait pas
les épaules pour réfléchir au ministère
de l'agriculture il ya on a dit que tu
tires l'humour avait tout envahi que
c'était une marchandisation qu'il avait
changé de nature parfois basculer dans
dans le ricanement qu'il avait parfois
du pouvoir et dans certains cas et le
gouvernent c'est beaucoup quand même
quand on ne suit vos risques dans
quelques années à président bien sûr
mais je me présente moi non mais est ce
que c'est vraiment ce qu'est ce que
poserait est ce que à partir du moment
où on est drôle on est humoriste mois
elle va rien savoir ou est ce qu'on mène
humoriste là dedans parce que le meurice
pour moi c'est un métier c'est sur scène
quand on est en chroniquant et
chroniqueur jamais proposé vous la
matinale voici enfin moi j'ai aussi mais
j'ai essayé quelques fois 6h55 en
pareille de noël et j'ai pas du tout
aimé l'expérience et j'avais séché noël
hynix et ouais chez ardisson aussi
j'avais essayé j'ai pas du tout aimé non
plus parce que là bas parce que mon
propos est dénaturée par le média en
fait
je pensais faire de la radio en fait
elle était filmée je pensais faire la
télé libre en fait elle était montée on
il y avait des choses qui disparaissait
au montage et où moi je trouve que la
création était un peu dénaturé parce que
je ne maîtrisais pas jusqu'au bout et
j'ai en fait je pense qu'il ya aussi un
problème c'est que il y a des gens à qui
on demande de faire de l'humour et de
devenir humoriste dans des émissions la
démission mais frédéric 1 a fait partie
à la base vous êtes écrit sauf que je
suis pas du tout humoriste vous êtes
écrivain on vous a demandé de faire des
blagues et il ya des humoristes à qui on
demande leur avis et donc on a un
mélange entre éditorialistes et
humoriste qui crée un oui mais parce que
c'est un abus de langage d'appeler ceux
qui font un métier de faire rire sur
scène de les appeler des humoristes on
les appelle normalement des comics
maintenant on ne veut plus qu'il existe
moins et pourtant c'est ça c'est des
conneries c'est quelqu'un à nu maurice
c'est pas un métier humoriste l'humour
c'est pas une discipline
d'accord c'est un état d'esprit peut
être aussi plein d'humour et en son sens
voilà cet humoriste accord séparé du
métier un métier d'écrire d'écrire
quelque chose sur scène et donc d'avoir
un espace de liberté sur scène qui n'est
pas le même que celui dans des médias
qui est donc dans l'immédiat elle est
très ramassé il faut être très efficace
moi j'aime pas du tout je n'ai pas
réussi à me prêter à l'exercice
et donc il ya une confusion un peu des
gens qui fait qu' il ya des gens qu'on
sort de scène pour aller faire des
blagues et qu'ils doivent absolument
être performant avec des gens qui les
jugent à côté et comme une espèce de
patron donc il ya eu aussi l'effet
inverse il ya le fait de pouvoir rire
parce qu'il ya texte qui s'est fait
virer de france 2 il ya jean marie
bigard qui a souffert de ses blagues
aussi donc on a l'impression d'être
moins d'essence hier
oui c'est une sorte de son 6e ce soir et
deux aides ou d'auto conviction qu' on
va dans la bonne direction donc on
s'autocensure sur le reste quoi c'est
super pour moi mais ça va j'ai ouais
c'est pas bien mais c'est pas bon ménage
non on a dit un truc quand même hyper
paradoxal je sais pas ce qu'on fait mais
vous allez compte juste vous dire une
chose qui est super intéressante on a
dit l'humour est de plus en plus partout
c'est devenu une sorte de prophétie à
c'est un job à part entière c'est la
marchandisation de l'humour en fait le
l'humour est est devenu politiquement
correct ça fait ça fait bien pas de pub
pas de fax ou injure que pas dormi non
et je vous inviterai surpasser votre à
monter moi je dis regarde et vous avez
raison mais la prochaine fois vous serez
viendrait serre mais en fait la viande
est de plus en plus pâles roland de rire
mais en réalité on se marre de moins en
moins et vous venez de le dire
tex vous avez raison bigard vous avez
raison je veux pas me faire que des amis
et chez les politiques c'est pareil en
ce y en a de moins en moins qui sont
marrant on se marrait chirac était
marrant non mais oh ouais t'es marrant
et pas seulement au fait qu'il ait fermé
et c'est le monde
l'humour est une denrée rare mais pas
forcément de génération en génération
vous restez avec deux jours et une toute
dernière question à la toute fin
d'émission à vous poser on veut savoir
si vous réfléchissez pendant ce temps là
avec le recul j'ai compris ce qui
s'était passé dans notre bon on va
accueillir président bush et pour
terminer cette émission et sa chronique
à ce qu'elle va nous parler d'une
émission attendue par certains peut-être
à droite de françois fillon ce soir
précis de boucher sa journée à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
bonsoir brigitte mon sens meriam alors
c'est le grand retour médiatique de
françois fillon ce soir sur le service
public n'y aura pas d'humoristes ça
c'est garanti deux journalistes deux
heures une heure et demie de tête à tête
avec neuf d'aller mais torres photo
comment la droite vigie tel cet
événement médiatique ce retour là bas
écoutez je pense qu'ils seront pas
devant leur télé en tout cas ceux que
j'ai interrogés m'ont dit non ça ne
m'intéresse pas non je ne serai pas
derrière la télé parce que ils ont
opportunément une réunion publique un
comité départemental qui fera qu' ils
auront une bonne excuse
certains disent peut-être que je règle
regarderai en replay d'autres disent oui
je vais regarder je suis curieuse de
savoir ce qu'il a à dire ça c'est une de
ses proches qui m'a dit ça alors à la
question de savoir qu'est ce que vous
attendez finalement de cette
intervention
eh bien ils disent rien ou vivent une
excuse mais la famille on est incapable
de cela il est beaucoup trop orgueilleux
la plupart en tout cas veulent tourner
la page
ils en ont assez alors il ya un député
qui est très agacé qui dit il a fait
beaucoup de mal à notre famille
politique qu'il ferme sa gueule
alors donc c'est ça arrive a évidemment
un mauvais moment en tout cas pour la
droite puisqu'il va y avoir un procès
qui s'ouvre oui alors là c'est vrai que
les républicains sont en pleine campagne
des municipales et ça arrive au plus
mauvais moment qui veulent reconquérir
le pouvoir
donc en fait ils tentent de minimiser
finalement de banaliser cette
intervention de françois fillon ils
feignent l'indifférence ils disent que
c'est un événement pour autant et bien
comme françois fillon ne reviendra pas
en politique
ils se disent que tout cela n'est qu'un
événement médiatique mais ça va quand
même remettre les affaires sur le devant
de la scène
et finalement on sait bien que ce procès
se tiendra en pleine campagne des
municipales
ça va donc faire un petit peu de mal à
droite et pourquoi at il souhaité cette
interview en saphir veut il veut livrer
sa part de vérité françois fillon lui
qui a brutalement quitté après 40 ans la
vie politique sur cet échec au premier
tour de 2017 ce soir-là il disait le
moment venu la vérité de cette élection
sera écrite ce moment est sans doute
arrivé pour pour lui on sait que son
procès se tiendra du 24 février au 11
mars
alors il veut dire sa vérité devant les
français avant de la dire devant les
juges son avocat dit qu'il a été
condamné par l'opinion il est donc
normal qu'ils se défendent devant le
tribunal qui l'a jugé
les députés disent qu'il veut laver son
honneur ne pas quitter la vie politique
sur une affaire de costumes
c'est un homme blessé il a été assassiné
médiatiquement boudine proches
son image est totalement décrédibilisée
alors autant qu'il dise ce qu'il a à
dire merci beaucoup brigitte on voit que
voilà les hommes politiques et les
affaires nourrir pour y fleurir du coup
les humoristes merci merci infiniment je
montre le livre parce qu'ils les
sentiers tracés l'homme qui pleure de
rire signé frédéric beigbeder et c'est
bien plus qu'un règlement de compte avec
france inter c'est une véritable
réflexion sur le rire la drôlerie dans
nos sociétés merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission
à demain
[Musique]